you guys they did it the rabbit has been
saved
I don't have 10 move from Craig Mason
so was the episode good yeah it was
pretty great we're kind of back to the
first couple of episodes in terms of
adaption where very little was changed
from the game to the show and this comes
with good reason because this portion of
the game was pretty amazing and
translates really well for the show now
obviously there are some action beats
that were removed from the game like
Ellie and David fighting off hordes of
Undead and Joel basically killing the
entire town but I think what was
retained was perfect for the show the
amount of dramatic buildup was balanced
out really well with the action and some
of the best scenes from the game made
its way into the show like Joel
interrogating the men for the location
of the Town Joel is not messing around
and seeing him without hesitation melds
right back into his more Savage past
self to find Ellie shows how much he
cares for her that's why him torturing
these people on the scene kind of
excites you because it ignites his drive
to find Ellie him doing these horrific
acts ironically expresses how much he
loves Ellie which this essentially leads
into my favorite aspect of this
particular story arc where it's set up
that Joel is going to be the Savior but
Ellie is the one to overcome all of the
conflict it makes her character
significantly more important within the
story because we seriously come to
extreme violent actions and she is able
to take care of herself I adore the
writing here from how clever it was for
Ellie to overcome David through quick
thinking and being smart the thing that
ironically saves her and buys her enough
time is her bite wound throughout the
show she has been told not to tell
anyone about it but the irony in that
her telling these people about it saves
her is extra juicy and R.I.P video game
Joel the amount of respect coming from
the creators in terms of the source
material and casting Legacy actors from
the games is really nice but going back
to the climax in an outstanding move by
Neil druckman he's simultaneously Nails
a big dramatic point for Ellie's
character while also defying set
expectations within storytelling in
which the main protagonist saves the day
that's why this segment of the story is
so genius is because it works so well on
both of these levels we are led to
believe that Joel will save Ellie
through him interrogating people just
for it to be more surprising when
Ellie's the one to kill David throughout
the sequence by utilizing parallel
editing the Creator set up a dual
perspective of Joel and Ellie with the
assumption that Joel will intervene at a
crucial point however that crucial point
isn't to save her physically and instead
emotionally she just brutally killed
another human being who is trying to
rape her and she is utterly broken the
only person in the world is safer from
this mental space is her now surrogate
father and the moment Joel calls her his
baby girl it's immense this emotional
bond even more it's okay baby girl
this dramatic payoff in their long
separation coming to close here is
immensely satisfying and is even more
powerful due to what Ellie just did
Bella Ramsey over the past two episodes
on their own puts her into the legendary
status for actors she has masterfully
portrayed the crazy lows and highs of
the character and every emotional beat
is done without faults I came into the
show expecting to be blown away by Pedro
Pascal's Joel but I ended up getting
floored by Bella Ramsey's performance
even more which doesn't mean that Pedro
is doing a bad job by any means the
acting is just on a completely different
level overall in comparison to other
shows looking more specifically at David
I think his adaption from the game is
also perfect I love the slow progression
throughout the episode as we learn
different reasons as to why this guy is
so messed up because it starts out with
him seemingly being a good guy but as we
peel away the layers he becomes more and
more like the Devil he's a manipulative
unfair cruel disgusting and vile a
person and seeing each one of these
traits reveal themselves was very fun
throughout the episode he's a very
engaging character because as a viewer
we need to see past this facade that
David is putting on to see his true
intentions him talking to Ellie while
she was in the cage is a great example
of this the entire time he's being
pretty vague and is clearly lying to
Ellie to win her trust then another one
of my favorite scenes was the dinner
scene where they were making the stew
and they brought in the quote unquote
deer meat at this point we assume this
is actually deer meat because the scene
prior showed us David in video game Joel
bringing back the deer only to reveal
that they walk in with the deer as they
are serving the food it cleverly hits
you with the oh [__] that is not deer
meat and it can only be something else
just a very smart way to communicate to
the audience what the meat is without
being obvious they do clearly confirm
that later on but that was more because
they wanted Ellie to find out they were
cannibals then also the small Touch
where David has a much bigger plate of
food in comparison to everyone else
portrays how much he exploits his power
you guys get to ration while I don't
these details within the script that you
can understand without them blatantly
telling you are Hallmarks of what makes
the script so great looking at Scott
Shepard who plays David I think he did a
good job at being a more chill warm and
inviting person to begin with it makes
his character so unsettling because we
know that he's the villain due to his
juxtaposition to our main characters and
we desperately try to figure out what is
wrong with him he's good at hiding his
intentions which in of itself is also
really terrifying for a one episode
villain this is a masterful example in
writing and to acting as to making a
compelling antagonist in a short amount
of time just very impressive overall
going into one complaint that I've been
seeing people say a lot that will
probably boil over here is the overall
lack of infected in comparison to the
game now this doesn't bother me because
the show takes a realistic angle in how
it tells its story Joel tells us Earl
early on that there are basically no
infected out in the middle of nowhere in
these Forest regions because logically
these are very rural areas if people
barely lived out here before the
outbreak then why would it make sense
for there to be a ton of infected here
along with being able to survive in
these harsh cold terrains that even
humans have to take shelter in this
isn't like The Walking Dead where there
are randomly hordes of zombies in the
forest at all times in that show it's an
obvious contrivance that the fans
naturally accept so they can see more
zombies however for the last of us it's
more grounded in how they treat the
mechanics of the World Neil and Craig
want to make an immersive and realistic
post-apocalyptic show not a flat out
zombie show this includes having threats
that are both infected and human so it
makes the most sense to have infected as
a threat when they are in cities and
when they aren't it makes more sense to
use humans because I know zombie
Fanatics will hate to hear this but the
human characters and villains have more
depth than zombies that's just how how
it is it's inherently more engaging to
follow the humans and although you can
create some outstanding zombie sequences
with Rich tension and action there's a
lot more variety in terms of what humans
can offer and the reason why those
zombie sequences like in episode 5 hit
so well is because they are used in
moderation also it's not like we're
deprived of zombies they've shown up in
half of the episodes so far and some of
the coolest sequences included them
using them more strategically in the
narrative increases their threat in
lethality and overall makes them more
menacing when they do show up I also
keep seeing people say that they hate
how a character always dies when an
infected is around and I'd argue that's
a good thing because they retain their
danger factor I want to be scared and
tensed up when the infected are on
screen and for it to not be like a
shooting gallery like in The Walking
Dead a couple of the other episode
specific complaints I've seen were the
fact that Ellie was let go so easily in
the beginning and the ending feeling
weird because the town felt non-existent
for the first one David's intentions
were pretty be clear and he wanted to
track Ellie back to where they were
hiding on top of him probably forming an
attraction to Ellie in this time so that
makes complete sense for the ending it
doesn't bother me that much that the
whole town wasn't present I feel like
focusing primarily on David was a lot
better than having Joel kill dozens of
people along with him being in a pretty
rough state so it'd be equally illogical
for him to take on that many people but
I can buy the fact that the town wasn't
alerted since she'll essentially wasn't
around for that long on top of the
building Ellie was in was not showing
much smoke externally also the town's
overall strength is already dwindling
and it seemed like David took as strong
as people with their gun supplied to
fight Joel and lost so even though the
ending in this regard has changed I
don't think it hurts the overall quality
of the episode you don't really need to
have Joel fight through all these people
because the dramatic emphasis is
primarily put on Ellie's shoulders which
she obviously delivers in Spades this
section of the story is about Ellie's
Independence and ability to take care of
herself against insurmountable odds
that's why it resonates so well because
the underdog conflict within this
episode is so strong Ellie can't rely on
Joel so it makes the obstacle she has to
overcome that much more palpable and
even Joel having to take on the writers
by himself was intense given how bad of
a condition he was in Craig Mason and
Neil druckman consistently deliver
scenes with so much suspense and weight
that the show always feels enjoyable the
grounded and realistic nature of the
show also helps us because the writers
don't introduce any [__] into the
script to cheat the conflict it's just
so refreshing having the show and even
their attention to detail and
authenticity of the environment elevates
the spreads like these actors were
getting rolled by the cold in this
episode poor Ellie face planting into
the snow was just feels bad man I'm
really excited going to the final
episode because if these past episodes
are this great then just wait and see
what the finale has in store for you
because it's going to be absolutely wild
thank you for watching and let me know
what you thought about episode 8 of The
Last of Us
foreign